dans les animateurs il y a ceux qui sont
en Ligue 2 Ligue 1 et la Ligue des
Champions il y en a il y en a quoi il y
en a trois quatre en Ligue des Champions
trois trois quatre
Ligue des Champions
c'est quoi la Ligue 1 voilà je vous dis
des animateurs vous me dites par exemple
je sais pas si je vous dis je vous dis
allez je vous dis par exemple je sais
pas moi
Stéphane Plaza
Ligue des Champions
très bien Mathieu de la Ligue nationale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ils mettent un jour de tennis mais
j'ai mis le grand jour de tennis là-bas
un jour de tennis et un journaliste et
un jour il y a journaliste qui dit au
jour de tennis voyons comment qu'on sent
quand on arrive en finale puis les gens
tennis qui dit bah je le sais tue moi
j'ai jamais été tu vois bah c'est un peu
pareil allez
on va essayer
de faire non mais c'était pour vous dire
que
gros animateurs de prime il y en a plus
beaucoup
un animateur c'est lui qui me laisse ça
marche
Ligue des Champions en Ligue des
Champions
et Mathieu tu vois il y a Mathieu il se
demandait pourquoi il a jamais été en
Ligue des champions
alors alors je vais te dire un truc qui
va te tuer le bec parce que là tout à
l'heure ça je tu vois ça ça m'énerve ça
ça c'est là ça n'était pas crédible
après parce que Mathieu au niveau talon
je peux te dire qu'il met tout le monde
à la ramasse ah mais je te le dis non
mais je le pense vraiment parce que tous
les animateurs là qu'on a cité Matthieu
au niveau Talo et je le pense vraiment
parce que j'en ai vu des animateurs il
est loin loin devant eux mais vraiment
loin je te le dis donc talent non talent
non je te le dis justement ton talent je
te jure et c'est un peu intéressant là
ce qu'on dit parce que on parle de télé
aussi ça c'est important Mathieu je te
jure que par rapport à ton talent pour
moi tu es l'animateur le plus talentueux
que j'ai rencontré et je ne rigole pas
non non franchement je le pense je te
les Gourcuff et je te l'ai déjà dit
d'ailleurs c'est vrai ou pas je te l'ai
déjà dit ou pas ouais c'est vrai c'est
vrai je te l'ai déjà dit c'est vous
l'avez même pas dit même dit à moi
un jour on a pris l'avion ensemble
c'était Las Vegas
et il m'a dit il m'a dit qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que tu penses que je dois
faire pour être pour devenir un
numéro un enfin d'être en Ligue des
Champions
je le pense vraiment aussi je pense que
au niveau talent il est au-dessus de
tout le monde mais tu es trop sensible
tu es trop fragile vous rien ne vous
attend non franchement non mais c'est ça
non mais c'est quand même incroyable
comment j'ai fait beaucoup de métiers
dans ma vie en finance tout ça j'en ai
fait beaucoup où j'étais nulle
et je m'étais trois coups de RAM comme
mes potes en mettait un je peux avoir la
prétention de dire que à la télé
vraiment sans prétention je trouve que
je ne vais pas la carrière de mon niveau
de mon talent je vous le dis il s'en
fout je suis enceinte
et il y a Stéphane Plaza et moi j'étais
fan bazar qui m'écrit d'ailleurs je
l'embrasse mon Stéphane aussi moi je le
mets Ligue des Champions je le dis c'est
vrai Stéphane Plaza pour moi c'est Ligue
des Champions Jean-Luc Reichmann c'est
Ligue des Champions
parce que Stéphane passage je veux dire
pourquoi je le mets Ligue des Champions
Stéphane Plaza sans Stéphane Plaza les
mecs une mission c'est pas la même
arrêtez Stéphane Plaza c'est une
personnalité non pour moi c'est
d'ailleurs moi moi c'est ça qui fait le
truc c'est quand tu es une personnalité
tu vois ou pas Stéphane Plaza tu
regardes Stéphane passage je suis désolé
des missions elle est super d'ailleurs
me disait c'est très simple c'est quand
un animateur est un concept tu dis j'ai
regardé il faut que j'ai regardé son tu
dis pas j'ai regardé TPMP j'ai regardé à
Nouna j'ai regardé
Pékin Express c'est vrai tu vois et
regarde l'amour est dans le prédit il y
a longtemps
c'est Ligue des Champions ça fait partie
du top 3 pour moi des animateurs les
plus talentueux de l'histoire avec
Delormeau
[Applaudissements]
des champions
Ligue 1 pour moi après voilà après
Ligue des Champions
ça a été mais bon merci